a dark lord wiped out by cgi a
heavyweight star saved from death in the
ring a martial arts icon replaced by a
cardboard cutout these are the fight
scenes that didn't go as planned for
better or for worse technically speaking
game of death was bruce lee's final film
released posthumously it tells the story
of martial arts star billy lowe who must
fake his own death to find out who's
trying to kill him around 40 minutes of
footage were shot before lee passed away
in 1973 but when the movie was finally
released in 78 only 11 of those minutes
actually made it into the film sadly
this means that most of the fight scenes
featured throughout the movie didn't
involve lee at all enter the dragon
director robert klaus was the man
brought in to finish the movie after
lee's death and he spent most of his
time finding inventive ways to not show
lee's character several doubles filled
in for the fight scenes including
martial artist yuen bial who had
previously doubled for lee and enter the
dragon as for the rest of the movie most
of the time lee's character is wearing
disguises hiding in the shadows or has
his face obscured one scene infamously
includes a cardboard cutout of lee's
face pasted on a mirror most importantly
nearly every fight scene features a
different actor pretending to be lee and
it's painfully obvious too nobody can
quite move like lee and it's clearly
impossible to replace a bona fide
martial arts legend
one of the most frequently discussed
scenes in quentin tarantino's once upon
a time in hollywood is the fight scene
between bruce lee and cliff booth the
two square off in a two out of three
falls fight lee picks up the first
knockdown booth picks up the second but
they're interrupted before they can
finish their match however this wasn't
the fight scene planned in the script in
fact the scene played out this way
because all parties involved held lee in
too high of a regard the third fight was
originally going to be much longer and
more competitive with cliff picking up
the victory via a cheap shot the goal
wasn't to show lee is weak though it was
to show how booth operated and made him
more credible as a fighter for the
audience it is after all the first time
we see booth throw down in the movie and
it's arguably his only fight against
someone trained for one however brad
pitt and stunt coordinator robert alonso
had reservations about lee losing given
his hollowed place in entertainment
history alonso had pitt and mike mo
train for months on the scene trying to
find a way for lee to lose without
tarnishing his image tarantino
eventually decided to have them
interrupted with no winner declared
the climax of the lord of the rings the
return of the king finds aragorn facing
off against a giant cave troll during
the big battle outside the black gates
it's a pretty great fight but it's
hardly the main attraction that's
probably because this scene wasn't in
the source material wasn't originally
shot that way and most importantly
wasn't supposed to happen at all when
wrapping up the trilogy the creative
team behind the lord of the rings had
two thoughts first sauron needed to
appear in some physical form besides the
great eye second aragorn needed to fight
sauron in some way in order to fulfill
his personal journey that's why an
entire sequence was scripted
storyboarded and shot in which sauron
shows up before the army of the west a
blinding white light appears and sauron
appears as anatar the angelic form he
took when he tricked the elves into
making the rings of power before taking
his true form and fighting aragorn but
the filmmakers soon realized this scene
just wasn't working it detracted from
sam and frodo's struggle in mordor and
undermined aragorn's role as a
self-sacrificing military leader it also
looked like a clunkier fight than they
originally wanted and we thought what's
a worthy foe for aragorn if it's not
going to be sauron and we thought well a
troll a big mean armored troll they
later repurposed the footage so that
aragorn would go toe-to-toe with the
massive troll resulting in an epic
battle of fantastical proportions
in a movie full of striking battle
scenes one of the most striking of all
in avengers endgame was the fight
between hawkeye and black widow in which
the two come to blows over who will
sacrifice themselves in order to acquire
the soul stone basically this scene
brought the superhero concept of
self-sacrifice to its literal and
logical end point it was also never in
the script and only came about in
reshoots when the original version was
already in the can the scene as
originally shot had thanos's army show
up at vormir leading to a small battle
between them and the two avengers during
the showdown natasha runs for the cliff
while clint tries to stop her and fight
off the attack at the same time the
scene tested well with audiences but new
ideas began to form by the time reshoot
started as such the filmmakers re-shot
the scene to make it more intimate
helping to better serve natasha's
character
it's hard to talk about dark phoenix
without discussing the movie's endless
reshoots and the controversy that
followed big chunks of the second and
third act were changed during production
including no fewer than two fight scenes
being wholesale reworked one of these
scenes was changed because it was too
similar to another superhero movie one
of the most hyped moments in dark
phoenix was a climactic attack on the
united nations building in new york
local media in montreal shared pictures
of the set and reports implied that
jessica chastain's character was a
skrull who would be part of the assault
by the time dark phoenix hit theaters
however the attack was
nowhere to be found the scene was
replaced by a much smaller scale fight
on a train likely shot on a sound stage
the united nations attack was also
supposed to feature a space battle
culminating in a full-blown alien
invasion of earth this was scrapped
because according to james mcavoy there
was too much overlap with a certain
other superhero movie considering the
nature of the scene and the timing of
the movie it seems likely that the movie
in question was captain marvel that's
why the scene was replaced with the
battle on the train a smaller scale
sequence that didn't exactly do the film
any favors
the terminator series has always been
renowned for its special effects winning
a ton of awards and acting as the
launching pad for a new generation of
special effects artists terminator
genesis took this to the extreme by
featuring a fight scene created entirely
with two cgi t-800s i've been waiting
for you the battle at griffith
observatory between the two t-800s was
featured prominently in the movie's
trailers however the filmmakers weren't
crazy about the scene after they'd
already finished filming the production
company wanted the battle to be more
brutal than originally shot but instead
of flying in arnold schwarzenegger and
the rest of the crew in for an expensive
reshoot they added to the fight scene
using two completely digital governators
the added scenes were far more violent
and they certainly would have been
difficult to pull off with human actors
the production team also used molds from
the original 1984 terminator movie to
make doubly sure the younger t-800 was
accurate
rogue one a star wars story ends with
darth vader single-handedly slaughtering
a hallway full of rebel soldiers before
the plans for the death star narrowly
escape his grasp it's a brutal one-sided
fight scene especially by star wars
standards it also wasn't in the movie's
original script rogue one attracted a
lot of attention for its reshoots even
though they're relatively common in
hollywood blockbusters in fact reshoots
are often built into a movie's
production schedule nevertheless those
utilized on rogue one were extensive
even by industry standards the original
plan here was to have the death star
data get to leia via a handoff process
with vader following in pursuit of
course the filmmakers decided at the
last minute to add a little kick to it
and they added the scene in which vader
actually boards the ship the result
nothing less than pure terror
rocky 5 finds the titular hero retired
from boxing due to brain damage and out
of money due to financial mismanagement
he takes young fighter tommy gunn under
his wing but the whippersnapper slowly
becomes resentful of his mentor the film
ends with gunn and balboa having a
street fight in which rocky is roughed
up but ultimately wins this victory
wasn't supposed to happen though and the
original ending was
much darker for most of the production
the planned ending was for rocky to die
in the street fight he would take a
great beating from gun and then die on
the way to the hospital in adrian's lap
she would then hold a press conference
telling the crowd that the spirit of
rocky lives on in people who believe in
themselves director john g appleton
thought it was a perfect ending and
stallone himself felt sick writing it a
few weeks into shooting however the
studio called avaldsen and forced him to
change it their reasoning heroes don't
die as such the fight scene was changed
adultson thought that the new ending
hurt the movie though telling 94wip
that rocky didn't die but the movie died
because that was the point of the movie
raiders of the lost ark is widely
considered one of the greatest adventure
films of all time part of its success is
attributed to harrison ford's indiana
jones who established himself as the
ultimate swashbuckling adventure hero
and one who isn't afraid to play dirty
indeed one of his most iconic fight
scenes from raiders of the lost ark was
also one of the most simplistic as a
swordsman spins his weapons around in an
impressive and terrifying display jones
takes the easy way out and does this
this hilarious battle is fondly
remembered by fans of the film but it
wasn't how the scene was originally
intended to play out in a reddit ama
ford revealed the reason for the change
saying i was suffering from dysentery
really and found it inconvenient to be
out of my trailer for more than 10
minutes at a time we'd done a brief
rehearsal of the scene the night before
we were meant to shoot it and both steve
and i realized it would take two or
three days to shoot this since he wasn't
feeling well and he had already done a
major scene against several villains
before that ford proposed to spielberg
that he'd just shoot the swordman
spielberg agreed and movie history was
made
ah
justice league the internet's biggest
talking point ever since comic book
movies became the next big thing the
many stories of warner brothers
interference in the production are
legendary with director zack snyder
stepping away due to personal tragedy
and the studio drafting joss whedon to
practically remake the whole movie
instead while
mustache gate dominated most of the
headlines there was one particularly
iffy action scene shot by whedon that
didn't feature in snyder's original cut
right at the start of the film batman
uses a thief as bait to draw out a
parademon the scene became known as
something of a joke due to batman openly
saying alfred's name possibly exposing
his secret identity what was that
a scout
from space
funnily enough the original scene was
even more whedonesque holt mckellany who
played the thief told men's journal my
scene with batman was originally
conceived as a comedic scene that's how
joss wrote it and that's how he shot it
i thought it came out great but the
studio felt it would be a mistake to
open the film with a completely comedic
scene so it was re-edited a little bit
according to mcallen whedon sent him a
bottle of champagne and a note as an
apology for the studio's changes
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]